I'm really delighted to introduce grace
Hong who is professor of gender studies
and asian-american studies at UCLA
professor Hong is the author of the
ruptures of American Capital women of
color feminism and the cultures of
immigrant labor published by the
University of Minnesota press in 2006
death beyond disavowal the impossible
politics of difference University of
Minnesota press 2015 which won the
Association for Asian American Studies
cultural studies book prize and she is
the co-editor with Roderick Ferguson of
strange affinities the gender and sexual
politics of comparative racialization
which was published by Duke University
Press in 2011 and over the last twenty
years she's been concerned to study the
gendered division of labor of racialized
immigrant laborers under US capitalism
in the 20th century her work describes
the racial engendered contradictions of
u.s. political economy in the transition
from national industrial capitalism to
de-industrialized global capitalism to
what we now call neoliberal finance
capitalism and she attends especially to
comparative racialization or the linked
yet differentiated impacts on black
indigenous and immigrant communities in
relation to those shifts it's also her
work is also concerned to consider Asian
American communities in a global frame
that includes racialization within the
United States as well as racialization
within US militarism and US Empire in
Asia moreover she considers women of
color feminism and women of color
expressive culture as the crucial
resource for the critical analysis of
global capitalism as both the
explanation for and the alternative to
the violence and impoverishment of our
current conditions she's helped us to
understand women of color not as a
category of identity but one that is
built through acknowledging and working
through differences her work has helped
us
vision of politics not premise Thanh the
suppression of differences but on
grappling with differentiated related
histories of racial enslavement
dispossession enclosure and exclusion
more importantly grace exemplifies these
ideas and her lived commitments as a
colleague teacher mentor and activist
we're grateful to have her share her
current work on Gina Kim's virtual
reality film bloodless dong do Chung
please join me in welcoming grace King
one prong oh I see got it
okay well everyone can hear me yeah okay
great so but you know many thanks to you
all for being here and of course you
know thanks to Lisa for organizing this
talk as well as just a really engaging
visit to her graduate seminar yesterday
you know many thanks to Lee AmeriCorps
for inviting me to participate in her
graduate seminar today and it's just
been this you know really amazing
opportunity to engage with old friends
and new that I am very very grateful for
so thank you so my presentation today is
on Gina Kim's Korean diceberg filmmaker
Gina Kim's bloodless or in Korean tong
du Chun a 12-minute non-narrative
virtual reality film shot in the camp
town or in Korean the kitchen of dong du
Chun near the US military bases Camp
Casey and
hubby and then those are about 40 miles
outside of Seoul South Korea so just you
know really quickly so in English the
title is bloodless in Korean its tongue
du chun and tong kitchen does not mean
bloodless it's the name of the camp town
so while the explicit aim of the film is
to engage the conditions of camp town
life and death and in particular to
recall the brutal murder of one
particular camp town sex worker it does
so in ways that are deeply ambivalent
about the logics of historical recovery
and narrative coherence as a means of
redressing historical and contemporary
violence instead bloodless mobilizes a
temporalities of contingency and an
aesthetics of perceptual uncertainty in
order to challenge rather than enhance
the assumption of verisimilitude and
transparency in other words the reality
of virtual reality so it does so out of
a desire for activation without recourse
to recognition you know and and the
recognition must be evaded if we are to
conjure up the long disavowed histories
of neo-colonial violence in the specific
context of present-day US Empire so so
Kim who teaches at my institution UCLA
in the school of theater film and
television is a much lauded director
who's working compasses both
award-winning experimental and
documentary films and commercially
successful feature films so her last
feature film final recipe starred
Michelle Yeoh and featured um
korean-canadian kpop artist Henry Lau as
a young man who enters a cooking contest
to try to save his grandfather's failing
restaurant
it opened in over 3,000 theaters in Asia
um you can watch it on Netflix
representing a departure from final
recipe to put it mildly
bloodless is Kim's first foray into
virtual reality filmmaking
and is also anomalous within her over in
that it is arguably her most overtly
political film today so as bloodless
requires a VR head gear and special
feeding it has mainly screen screened at
film festivals museums and universities
it has gathered much acclaim on the film
festival circuit where independently
produced VR films have flourished late
and bloodless has won several best VR
Film Awards at these film festivals it
also screened at the Seoul International
Women's Film Festival in the summer of
2018 where which was the first time it
reached a largely South Korean
viewership so bloodless is a hybrid film
that blends together documentary and
fictionalized elements in order to
depict the last hours of the life of
young Kumi a sex worker in Hunger Chun
who was tortured raped and murdered in
1992 by Kenneth lemarchal a US Army
medic because of the extreme brutality
of the crime alongside a growing culture
of social protest in the wake of the
student democracy movements against
military dictatorship which trans in
which which ushered in a transition into
democratic governance in 1987 Yuans
murder sparked a sustained campaign that
led to the subsequent arrest and trial
of her murderer Korean and international
feminists and anti US military activists
were galvanized by this event and it was
largely due to their if efforts that
Marco was tried and convicted in Korean
courts rather than by the US military
which was a first at the time so Marvel
was sentenced to 15 years which he
served in a Korean prison and was
released in 2006 so Kim who was a
college student in 1992 narrates her
politicization and identity as a
feminist as inaugurated by the
organizing around Yuans murder
she has also discussed her many
attempts to make a film about yen over
the decades you know since this
politicization attempts which always um
stalled until she hit upon the medium of
VR so while Markos case may have seemed
to signal South Korea's defiance of
their usual relationship of subservience
to US military interests such a reading
must be contextualized within the
decades long history of u.s.
neocolonialism in the region this
relationship has shaped much of South
Korean society politics and economy in
the post-world War two ERA but but both
South Korean and US national cultures
have ambivalently narrated and more
often disavowed this conjoin history
particularly in relation to military sex
work while the so-called comfort women
who were coerced into sexual slavery by
Japanese colonial forces during World
War two are perhaps the most well-known
example militarized sex work has long
been a fact of life a key economic
driver and a political necessity in
South Korea as Kathryn moon has noted
sex work is the quote raison d'être of
the kitchen and quote and there is a
camp counselor which has seen continuous
US military presence since 1945 while
sex work is technically illegal under
South Korean law it has always been
tacitly encouraged while officially
South Korean citizens military sex
workers have been regulated not owned by
not only the South Korean state but by
the US military which has colluded to
subject them to invasive STD checks and
has turned a blind eye to conditions of
near indentured servitude and to
systemic abuse and violence at the hands
of their clients as such Jody Kim has
argued that the camp town is a deathly
space one in which overlapping
sovereignties South Korean and US create
a necro political state of precarity
protected by neither state that the
sleeves residents constantly vulnerable
to death
the camptown sex-worker necessary but
disavowed was for a long time unable to
be murdered or mourned because her life
was never protectable in the first place
so this is a historical backdrop to his
case which was unusual not because
camptown sex workers had previously not
been subjected to extreme violence but
because there was such widespread
outrage about what had been by that
point a decades-long situation ignored
or excused by both the populace at large
and by the South Korean state while
Young's death became what grace choked
halls boat a transnational macro
spectacle and quote she writes that it's
a typical hyper visibility provides no
more agency to yawn nor does it give us
any more access to her than does the
invisibility of the uncountable
unmourned Cho refuses to frame the
widespread recognition of Young's murder
through a redemptive narrative of
justice brought about you know for
example by the South Korean states you
know successful conviction and
punishment of Markel at the same time
Cho also refuses to foreclose the
possibilities of other more inchoate
manifestations of agency for Cho Young's
death is a form of spectral haunting she
writes that quote in its travels it
haunted the imaginations of Korean
feminists as well as anti us activists
on the peninsula
end quote you know and Gina Kim you know
explicitly counts herself amongst these
Korean feminists for which state justice
is no resolution as Cho reminds us quote
the ghosts have an agency of their own
and quote in this context the question
is how to raise histories of violence
without subjecting these histories to
the desire for resolution and
reparations that as Lisa yoneyama
compellingly argues undergirds US Empire
so
you know um haunting is perhaps the only
adequate rejoinder to the particularity
z' of a specifically neoliberal
manifestation of US Empire in which an
imperial self critique ends up
legitimating rather than undermining its
imperial ambitions
so in cold war room in ruins yoneyama
notes that the hallmark of post-world
War of the post-world War two ERA is the
conundrum that the very idea of
recognition and remedy for historical
justice in Justices replicates the
violence's of u.s. militarism and hides
the tracks of present-day US empire so
yoni Yama calls this quote the
Americanization of post 1990s redress
and reparations so for instance yoneyama
argues that the vision of the United
States is a benevolent force
disseminating democracy through
throughout the u.s. person of the
asia-pacific region is supported in
large part through its purported ability
to both punish war Japanese war crimes
and to reckon with its own legacies of
wartime violence
so I'm likewise needeth honest oski
observes the ways in which cinematic and
literary narratives of the Vietnam War
encouraged us audiences to understand
themselves and u.s. foreign policy by
extension as moral precisely because
they engaged in self critique of the
violence and devastation wrought on
Vietnamese lives thus the very notion
that the violence of war can be
redressed is itself an important aspect
of u.s. post-war hegemony what we'll
find in bloodless however is that in the
realm of the Haunted and the ghostly
recognition or redress are deeply
irrelevant as such bloodless refuses
recognition and it does so that through
the mobilisation of aesthetics and form
that departs from vrs conventional
applications these conventional
applications have been
in a twist of appropriate irony
innovated by the US military so while we
may more readily associate VR technology
with gaming the earliest driver of
virtual reality technology development
was the US military so the u.s. so the
US military developed VR for use as
trained in training simulations and as
and as therapies for veterans suffering
from PTSD so in other words before and
after actual insertion and war so the
military's use of VR technologies in
both contexts and in particular its
emphasis on the importance of VRS
verisimilitude has been fertile ground
for its self narration as ethical and
humanitarian so and and so this is an
example of the therapeutic uses of VR
this is which I'll talk about in a
second so um all right
an early VR innovator and the main
producer of VR technologies were used by
the military is the Institute for
Creative Technologies ICT at the
University of Southern California an
elite private school located across town
from my institution ICT was founded in
1999 so I mean easily think about like
1999 that was like so early for VR right
um through a forty five million dollar
grant from the US Department of Defense
the DoD so international security
theorist James George Orion identifies
the establishment of ICT as the
inauguration of what he calls the quote
military-industrial media entertainment
network and quote to which I'd add the
university as a non institutional
non-incidental institutional partner and
and he has this really interesting sort
of theorization of the ways in which you
know LA was really important because
access to sort of media industries which
was necessary for you know doing all
this VR work so ICT has developed
several VR technologies in conjunction
with the DoD including a training work
program called flat world from 2001 to
2007 and a PTSD treatment program called
brave mind 2005 to 2010 used which has
created so brave mind is the project
which created the VR exposure based
treatment program called virtual Iraq
and then later renamed virtual Iraq and
Afghanistan that's like and then like
virtual Syria virtual Yemen I mean just
can just keep going on and on and on so
so okay in any case so these early VR
projects flat world and brave mind
engage temporalities of oops let me
engage temporalities of resolution and
the aesthetics of verisimilitude
to advanced individual individuated by a
logistic decontextualized and a
historical definitions of agency and
trauma and in so doing replicated the
notion of the military as a humanitarian
and ethical endeavor so VR supposin
capacity for realism and their
similitude becomes central to this
narrative of ethicality so new media
scholar lucy such mins analysis of flat
world demonstrates that for the military
its efficacy is based on its capacity
for verisimilitude and thus any
narratives about flat world must elide
any of the inevitable breaks or
discontinuities between the virtual and
the run and the actual this framing of
VR provides the specific ideological
legitimation x' required by the
strategic and ethical dilemmas of the
you know quote unquote war on terror
that is as commonly observed the war on
terror is
not fought in conventional ways you know
with a clear battlefield on which two
forces confront each other but is
instead fought through occupation and
insurgency so in this context who is the
enemy and whom the beneficiary of US
military protection can be difficult if
not impossible to didn't delineate
mainly because occupation sort of
necessarily means that everyone is
suspect so the use of VR technologies
allows the military to obfuscate this
condition by asserting the possibility
of a discerning between enemy and Ally
so Suchman recounts that in 2006 a flat
world VR technology was incorporated
into the Marines infantry immersion
trainer built in Camp Pendleton
California located about 50 miles north
of San Diego so the IIT was a hybrid
installation which mixed built
environments live-action actors and VR
technologies to quote-unquote fully
immersed pre deployment Marines in a
reconstructed Iraqi village in order to
present them with ostensibly hyper
realistic combat situations so Marines
performed house searches under
conditions that mimicked the noise smell
heat and chaos of combat and were
presented with scenarios involving
figures marked as insurgents as opposed
to those marked as civilians that is
women and children during which they
were called upon to make snap decisions
about when to fire and whom to fire upon
so it you know it's obviously kind of
the gamification of this kind of
training which is you know really
interesting to think about also such
simulations are purported to enhance
ethical decision making central to these
claims is VR technology's ability to
faithfully recreate combat conditions so
as to inoculate military personnel to
the stresses of combat so such men
observes that despite the many lapses in
VR technology that undermine this
mention of disbelief you know and it was
in 2006 and you know like obviously the
VR doesn't look that great as well as
the inherent contradictions of a
training that purported simultaneously
to quote sharpen combat instincts and
reinforce ethical conduct end quote
so despite all of these lapses both of
the command structure and the Marines
who participated in the trainings
emphasized IITs fidelity to field
conditions as a signal of its
effectiveness
VRS fully immersive quality and it's
supposed verisimilitude in other words
buoys a technological utopianism that
legitimates US military violence by
making Marines more discriminate
discriminating in their killing and by
creating and reinforcing distinctions
between dangerous insurgents and
innocent civilians so put another way in
implying that flat world and IIT can
produce ethical soldiers it represents
the moral failings of war as limited to
individual mistakes of judgments rather
than as a fundamental condition of war
itself so um a second military
application of V are the brave mind
projects virtual Iraq program likewise
emphasizes narratives of verisimilitude
this time in VR s clinical application
particularly as a way to delineate the
relationship between war trauma and
memory so virtual Iraq began as recycled
visual and graphic elements from a
simulation training program much like
flat world virtual Iraq was later
speaking of gamification released as a
commercial first-person shooter video
game called full-spectrum warrior and I
was in 2004 so virtual Iraq is a PTSD
treatment protocol that replicates
traumatic events experienced by military
personnel suffering from this clinical
condition that has been called quote a
disorder of time patients are fitted
with a VR headset
headphones and stand on a podium that
mimics the kinetic yep I thought I had a
photo of it um that mimics the kinetic
sensations of explosions so you're like
on a platform and as you're like
watching the VR like the platform will
shake when an explosion got was off in
the distance
they're also outfitted with controllers
that that hyper realistically mimic
weaponry such as a rifle
so although the clinical rationale
behind this form of treatment predates
the advent of VR technology the
incorporation of VR enables a fantasy of
an ever more effective cure for the
violence's of war so that this clinical
rationale um has been termed exposure
based treatment and it hypothesizes that
PTSD symptoms can be ameliorated by
guiding patients to remember repeatedly
the traumatic event in detail
habituating them to the experience the
thought is that over time and with
repeated exposure the traumatized
involuntary emotional reactions
eventually abate rendering the memory
less debilitating and this is a very bio
Logistics sort of neuro scientific
approach to PTSD so so adding VR
technology to this exercise so you can
do it without VR right so what you do is
you just kind of like recount the
experience and describe it over and over
again to your therapist but adding VR
technology to this exercises I'm thought
to make these memories more realistic
and detailed and further because the
clinician has full control of what
happens in the simulation VR disables
the patient's psychic defense mechanisms
the repression of these traumatic
memories for example or other tactics of
avoidance so the military's clinical
uses of VR technology operate on the
logic of habituation or in other words
the retraining of brain and nervous
system functions in ways that place
emphasis on psycho biology new media
theorist Posse Valle aho notes that
expose
therapy relies on the notion that PTSD
is an inappropriate manifestation of
like brain and nervous system biology
rather than predicated on an arat
illogical basis of subjectivity
so while Valley aho does not state so
explicitly this approach to PTSD you
know obviously departs from earlier
definitions of trauma descended from
psychoanalytic frameworks which defined
trauma as a breakdown in the psyches
ability to narrative eyes and thus
assimilate an event into a coherent
narrative of the self
so rather exposure based therapy posits
that PTSD is caused by the brain and
nervous systems instinctual responses to
danger as an important survival
mechanism that glitches when it's
triggered even when the organism is not
actually in physical peril so PTSD
treatments such as virtual Iraq
ostensibly work by changing
physiological reactions to traumatic
memory by in effect retraining the brain
and its autonomic central nervous system
functions so the narrative contours of
the memory itself is then not
necessarily under manipulation but the
patient's physiological and affective
reactions the therapists task then is to
treat PTSD as a series of responses to
stimuli rather than to frame it as an
embodied and sublated mediation of war
the temporalities of trauma in which
past experience is unrepresentable but
palpably felt in the present is reduced
to an individual disorder of physiology
that can be managed by being subsumed
into a linear temporalities of illness
and cure so while vali aho is critical
of these you know vr uses of technology
he read he replicates the d
contextualization and bio biologists
that bio violetta cessation inherent to
medical discourses and that he
uncritically takes up the notion that vr
operates simply
on the brain and nervous system Oh with
the actual sort of content of these
images much less the context being
somewhat in irrelevant
in contrast bloodless highlights the
colonial gendered and sexualized nature
of the violence that war and militarism
inflicts not only or even centrally on
the soldiers who turn the violence on
themselves you know through PTSD as a
manifestation of what Valley aho terms
neoliberal autoimmunity but on so-called
enemy populations and very often you
know the violence is also against the
Allies that u.s. militarism is supposed
to protect right the experience of
bloodless in contrast is to scramble vrs
mobilization of verisimilitude to
provoke feelings of alienation and
spectral embodiment so bloodless works
to connect embodied and affective
experience and narrative and imagistic
content in order to make resident
resonant the violence of CAM town life
and death rather than understand trauma
as an individual embodied response to
violent conditions the film references
trauma as a historical event and so here
I want to return to grace chose work
because I find chose um understanding of
trauma very instructive
so her framework understands trauma as a
response to violence rendered unnerve
all trauma is quote the excess that
escapes symbolization end quote
this unmerited and unmerited bility
occurs not simply because of a patient's
inability to create a coherent narrative
out of the experience of violence or
because of a glitch in the patient's
autonomic systems but because the memory
of violence is foreclosed multiple-- as
a function of an historical and
political erasure for show the quote
fabric of erasure and quo
is woven from the shame of unequal power
relations between South Korea and the
u.s. which requires at South Korea be
grateful for us militarism and
neocolonialism despite the massive toll
that such relations take this tall choe
argues is most emblematic aliy
represented but also disavowed in the
figure of the military sex worker /
military bride referenced by the
derogatory epithet young gwangju which
is itself a figure that represents the
quote spectral force that made visible
the continuing traumas of u.s. military
domination end quote the young Jew is
not an anomalous figure then but one
that it Pitta mises the condition of
South Koreans Korean migrants and Korean
Americans for whom assimilation to u.s.
narratives of benevolence and salvation
is both a requisite and violent even
more broadly the structure of forgetting
that Choe describes is not limited to
the Korean condition rather quote The
Forgotten War is also a metaphor for a
hegemony that depends on not seeing the
violence's that have created its ghosts
and quote thus if the military's use of
VR is predicated on the notion that this
technology gives us increasingly
truthful and realistic modes of seeing
and recalling Cho argues that this very
claim to omniscience creates the
structure of a ratio so Cho suggests
that traumas disorganization of
narrative means that it does exist on an
embodied can kinetic and affective
register so unlike the epistemological
framework of exposure-therapy predicated
on physiology however chose deployment
of the concept of synesthesia allows for
an understanding of traumas operating on
a historical as opposed to only on an
individual register Cho writes quote
when the subject cannot
her own history when history is
unintelligible or made unintelligible
who or what speaks for her the thing
that cannot directly be spoken becomes
the phantom that works like a
ventriloquist like a stranger within the
subjects own mental topography and quote
so when Cho references you know the
subject who cannot speak her own history
she is in part referencing the young
gongju the camptown sex-worker so in the
case of bloodless that would be you know
kind of literally young kameen however
if we take Cho's argument that the young
Gong Joo is a figure for all those who
wrestle with this hegemony that depends
on not seeing the violence is that have
created its ghosts all those who are
foreclosed from knowing the past because
of the erasers of the present we might
also think of the filmmaker and the
viewer as likewise animated or haunted
by these traumas of historical violence
so so I'm going to show the bloodless
trailer but I want to sort of put a
caveat so unlike you know regular film
you know VR film like you can't just
clip it and show it obviously right you
need the whole like set up so the only
thing I can show you is this trailer but
this trailer is very non representative
because it's not even a clip right it's
a trailer and so it has a music on it
which the film does not have and it's
sort of just these clips but at least
you can sort of sort of see the general
aesthetic and and the kind of evocative
nature of this film so
[Music]
okay oops sorry sorry about all this
flickering let me um put this back up so
I wonder actually if I can I'm sorry get
it to just be in that spot where we can
see her face yeah there we go
oh I keep missing it okay you know what
let me just not fuss with it so um okay
so um so bloodless dis organizes any
sense of a progressive temporalities of
resolution and undermines the suspension
of disbelief that enables um the
presence of the pretense of
verisimilitude so bloodless begins with
shots of the actual camp down of tongue
diction which is like still an active
camp town in daylight so the first scene
is of a stray dogs standing in the
corner of an alley while uses useful for
technical orientation right so the
assistant who was helping me with a VR
headset and everything asks me to let
him know when I see the dog so that he
knows that the film has started
correctly so the viewer sudden placement
in this scene immediately establishes
both the feelings of disorientation and
of strange quiet intimacy that pervade
this film the streets are only lightly
inhabited a Korean man bikes past
seemingly unaware of the camera of
ragged cut and two US Army soldiers in
t-shirts camouflage pants and boots walk
past i am the camera with curiosity or
perhaps suspicion or perhaps a
self-consciousness of being filmed while
entering what looks like a club so
eventually the film cuts to a scene at
night of a dark empty street before we
see her we hear the footsteps of a woman
walking in high heels
the solitary figure of yun played by an
actress wearing a mini dress hose and an
oversized army jacket draped
over her shoulders walks into the frame
the camera follows her as she walks
alone in nonchalant after a presumable
night in the clubs the streets and
alleyways are empty the businesses are
shuttered and the sound of her heels
echo off the buildings throughout Yun is
staged and performed as nine they're
vulnerable nor particularly a gential
she walks unheard leaf through the
streets her clothing references her
occupation as a bar girl but she's not
framed by the camera in a particularly
sexualized manner and her embodiment and
movement is ordinary and prosaic you
have this literal description and this
you know conventional film trailer
cannot fully convey the experience of
the film bloodless is experienced
through a VR headset and headphones with
the viewer seated in a rotating decks
desk chair I actually think she just put
everyone in a desk chair so we would
like fall over and hurt ourselves but
once in the headset the viewer has a 360
degree view of the scene on every axis
while the term virtual reality conjures
the idea of a fully immersive experience
that ostensibly feels more lifelike than
other cinematic media the predominant
experience of bloodless is that of
ghostliness a kind of unreal half-life
the experience for the viewer is eerily
disembodied unlike in first-person
shooter games or for that matter in
military simulations there is no
representation of the viewers limbs or
body and no way for the viewer to affect
their surroundings resulting in a
feeling of vulnerability and
defenselessness this feeling of
vulnerability is exacerbated by the 360
degree immersive environment in which
something could be approaching the
viewer from any direction at any time
regardless of where the viewer happens
to be looking so the viewers experience
is that of passive witness able to sense
see and hear but never to impart or
intervene
the feeling is that of liminality of
being both present and absent of being
unsure where one ends and another begins
of a profound disruption to the sense of
embodied boundaries so the viewers
ghostliness is mirrored by that of yun
who is apparitional both because we know
that she is a representation of an
already dead and indeed murdered person
but also because the film represents her
as somewhat spectral even in life so her
movement through the deserted streets of
chengdu chun is noticed by noah and she
interacts with noah underscoring her
exceptionality and that of the camp town
itself bloodless is steeped in the
neither here nor there precarity of camp
town life the emptiness of the city is
certainly due to the exigencies of
covertly filming in an active camp town
with no with no permits which meant that
Kim and her production staff had to film
in less trafficked areas and at night
when streets were more likely to be
deserted
yet by combining this emptiness with the
deliberate pacing of the scenes the kind
of icy blue light and the lack of an
extra diegetic soundtrack Kim amplifies
the solitude into an aesthetic so in one
particularly disconcerting seen the
ghostliness of both the viewer and the
figure of yun comes to a head and that's
actually kind of why I wanted to pause
it but I was not did you wanted to see
it again okay yeah yeah so I want you to
also just pay attention to this last bit
where she's looking at you so
[Music]
[Music]
okay so let me just stop it right there
because this is this I'm gonna talk
about this part right now so interesting
so in one particularly disconcerting
seen the ghostliness of both the viewer
and the figure of Yin comes to a head
the scene opens with the viewer facing a
wall in a dark narrow alleyway again we
hear the footsteps approaching this time
from our left Yuans figure then emerges
from the dark approaching the viewer
until she has stopped and is staring at
or possibly through the viewer with the
serious unreadable expression on her
face like this expression right here all
right um so um you know this this
expression is so interesting you know
because it's like you know it's so
unlike is it accusatory is it you know
um anyway so diverting our view from Yin
does not alleviate this discomforting
sensation but in many ways makes the
scene even more eerie as doing so means
knowing that you know we're still being
watched by her so you don't have to look
at her you can look away because that's
like VR but it's like you know there's
like some imeem someone looking at mmm
all right Yun never explicitly
acknowledged the viewer either by
gesture or expression and one is never
entirely sure if she sees the viewer or
if the viewer is invisible to her a
sense that is unnerving ly exacerbated
when she continues her journey which the
VR technology makes feel as if she is
walking through the viewer it's so
interesting it really does feel like
she's walking through you so the scene
and the manner in which the actor plays
Yun is ambiguous was there an actual
interaction between yin and the viewer
was an aware that the viewer was even
there or was the encounter accidental
and coincidental a situation in which
the viewer ghostly and apparitional
happened to be in her path this
encounter which is not an encounter a
scene of questionable recognition
the last scene of the film shifts from
this more evocative spectral mode to one
more reminiscent of the horror genre
interestingly enough a jump cut finds
the viewer in Yun's motel room a cramped
yellowing space all we see at first are
the cracks in the walls and a discolored
linoleum covered floor seemingly empty
but for Yun's oversized jacket hanging
in a corner a bag of sodas a full-length
mirror propped in one corner and a
crumpled blanket strewn along one wall
footsteps that we now recognize as Yun's
approached the door from the street and
eventually stopped right outside but no
one enters gradually depending on when
and whether it happens to catch the eye
blood seeps from underneath the blanket
pooling slowly toward where our feet
would be several beats later but again
depending on when and whether it catches
the eye the dead and violated figure of
young crumpled next to the blanket
appears in the reflection in the mirror
but not in the room itself so the
feeling of this scene may be akin to
those summoned by the conventions of a
horror film a sense of vulnerability of
creeping ominous danger interrupted by a
sudden gruesome shock at the same time
this scene operates on a temporalities
of contingency because it is entirely
possible that the viewer may never have
seen Yun's body at all depending on
where the viewer happens to be looking
when when that when the body appears in
the mirror and in fact one of the people
that I went to see this screening with
didn't realize until afterwards when I
and you know the third person that I
went to see this screening with me we're
talking about oh my god the body in the
mirror and she said the what in the one
and she hadn't missed it completely yeah
so so that the shock of seeing Yun's
body is exacerbated exacerbated by the
viewers realization
that one's own movements and decisions
affected exactly when and whether one
saw the image and that there may
actually be no shock actually because of
this condition destabilizes the ethics
of witnessing so bloodless those throws
the throws into crisis the idea that VR
enhances ethical decision-making instead
ethical indeterminacy is the main effect
of the film so who the viewer is in
bloodless is and what our role might be
is raised but never answered structured
by a temporalities of contingency rather
than resolution the film explicitly
troubles rather than assumes or enhances
verisimilitude it emphasizes rather than
undermines the incommensurability of the
physical and the virtual ghostliness in
this film is an embodied feeling as well
as a theme triggering a feeling of
perceptual indeterminacy bloodless
attests that trauma is historical memory
manifests an embodied ineffective ways
yet suggested suggest that this
manifestation is uneven uncertain and
hardly predictable so in so doing
bloodless gestured to other embodiments
other possibilities beyond the terrors
of killing in the cop in the guise of
justice thank you
oh okay sure yeah that's probably a good
idea okay
hello I can see it Daphne brick
I see the first part yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
maybe actually you know so yesterday
after the graduate seminar I was sort of
talking to some of the grad students and
you know this is the thing about this
film right which is that when you make
an argument about something you're like
making an argument but I still have a
lot of feelings about this at home that
are very unresolved right and it you
know and then the fact that you know I
know Gina and then she's like a friend
of mine and a colleague and you know
that makes it so that I don't you know
like being hypercritical in the film
that's made by a friend of yours is also
a little bit fraught you know and and
and it's not like I would be
hypercritical of this film but you know
what's really interesting about this
film is that you know and the way that
Gina presents this film is that like
it's it's very at the same time like you
know so it's won a bunch of awards in
like a kind of like easily film festival
circuit right and these sort of elite
you know pretty why eat you know film
festival audiences like love this film
right
the South Korean folks at the South
Korean women's Film Festival also really
liked the film she was really nervous
about it and she's like oh my god what
if they hate it but they really like
responded well to it so um and then you
know and as I said you know Jean
like like a commercial filmmaker right
like she's actually working on TV right
now because she's want to travel too
much and she's like I teach in LA so I'm
gonna work on TV and the way she
represents this film is she's just like
like parts it like parts of it are just
like yeah you know I sort of didn't want
this to be like a kind of
memorialization of her I wanted to
destabilize things but then she's also
like oh it's so great that this is gonna
get circulation because it's gonna
really raise awareness you know
absolutely no no it's very kind of you
know like basically the only sound you
hear her footsteps yeah yeah so of
course there's no dialogue she's sort of
alone I'm trying to remember now if like
the dog barks or anything you know at
the beginning and now I can't I can't
remember I need to pay more attention to
that the next basic this film
but anyway it's very it's it's very like
that there's and this music is not at
all
yeah yeah so I don't mean I don't know
how mass-circulation this trailer is
actually because you know it's it's it's
like a 12-minute both virtual reality
like sort of niche film you know so it's
theirs and theirs but but certainly you
know more people have seen this trailer
then have seen the VR film you know so
and yeah I mean in a lot of ways you
know that the trailer you know like I
think what's interesting about the
trailer is that it doesn't prepare you
at all for watching movie in a good way
you know so yeah yeah I mean and it's
it's not like I'm saying that it's some
I mean the in terms of the mood that it
evokes I think it's very you know
resident like if if the film were to
have music it would be this music but I
mean that's what this music is a feeling
of the film you know but yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
apparatus as well as the representation
in relationship to its origins of
production as a military mm-hmm and the
way in which it excuse temporalities use
the formation of the so-called ethical
decision of whether to shoot or dawn
mm-hmm and just places and reorients
that what i what i wanted to ask you to
do war was sure talk about how it change
I change its verisimilitude and maybe
it's because I don't know so much about
virtual reality you know what I mean for
me I think the way that it challenges
their similitude is that you're just so
ghostly you know it's that disembodied
feeling right because you know I mean
they're starting this way in which
you're like wow I'm in tone Duchin but
like yeah is so disconcerting like it's
really hard to explain if you're not in
it you know I'm and and there's
something and and you know there are
other like a lot of virtual reality
things are kind of disembodied in that
way because it's just a lot easier to
make VR films that don't have
representations of people's bodies you
know and that aren't interactive right
but I think there's something about the
pacing and the mood and the lighting and
and the abrupt kind of you know cuts
from scene to scene that you're
constantly feeling a little bit
disoriented and that sort of produces
this feeling of vulnerability that like
makes that disembodiment feel really
palpable right so so you know for me you
know the fact that you can kind of look
around and see everything didn't
actually result in the feeling of like
gee I'm really there it was the feeling
of like oh my god I'm kinda happy do I
exist join
like Who am I yeah so I think that would
be my main you know oh for sure right
yeah yeah right right
ya know if you have thoughts about how
she's trying to critique the yeah yeah
yeah absolutely
Euler order that we're in now under yeah
no that's absolutely right well no it
really doesn't and doesn't kind of
prepare you for it or anything right um
so there's so many different ways of
responding to that you know one I mean I
think you know is sort of the idea of um
you know like like cinema and VR is a
kind of heightened form of cinema I mean
if er does share a lot with I mean with
cinema you know what I mean like a lot
of the VR folks in like new new media
studies and cinema studies you know have
made the argument which i think is is
pretty compelling that that there are as
many connections as there are
disjunctions between vr cinema and like
regular you know cinema so and a part of
the the kind of the this part of the
thing of cinema is that it's about sort
of like seeing right and and and
visuality and then you know and VR is
about like the the kind of presumption
that you can see more you know so you
know so so you know that's obviously a
part of you know if there's a way of
thinking about it and you know if you
think about the what say like we say
yoneyama and naida at anasazi and those
folks are saying right is that this
contemporary moment of us Empire is
about saying like even the critique like
even the self critique is gonna like
replicate right and so there's this kind
of like expanding totalization of like
recognition and redress and and like
visibility and and you know what I mean
in stately you know that you know like
as we see with the military applications
of VR technology is like entirely wetted
in that logic you know yeah so I mean so
the the ways in which you know bloodless
really kind of interrupts that in a
variety of ways through VR technology
but also like through its use of the
technology right sort of troubles that
in these different ways so but
question about how that specifically
relates to the conditions of like
occupation and insurgency I'm gonna have
to think on that a little bit more you
know like that part of it but that's a
really helpful question and like a
really productive direction to go with
this I think like that I'm gonna have to
think on a little bit more um so I think
Alicia had a hand up before and then
we'll go to ride or is that okay
yeah exactly
yep yep
mm-hmm
yeah
yeah
yeah
hmm oh I see what you're saying yeah
you know I didn't know if you had a
sense of her feet
absolutely that is such a good set of
questions it's not that's so not even
just one question it's like like so many
questions no no let me try to keep all
that out that's so good okay so yeah the
first thing is that you know yes of
course like what this does is it makes
you so passive right and so you know and
so there is no opportunity for like
either sort of like redemption or or
failure for you in this right except
insofar as going back to it China was
saying the ethics of witnessing right
but even that then is undermined because
you could just miss it
you know so I think a part of what that
is doing is sort of saying you know it's
just like it's just like it's just not
it's indeterminate its condition it's
contingent it's like the temporalities
of contingency you know and that there
is no kind of like you know pure sort of
moment of you know so one thing right
that I think this particular scene does
when she kind of walks through you right
and you're not sure what have you is
that it makes it so that it's really
clear that you and she cannot interact
right and because a number of people
have asked about this who haven't seen
this like well could you be the killer
like could you be in the the figure of
the killer and you kind of can't right
because like if you were the killer why
would you walk through you know what I
mean so but but there's sort of this way
in which the the idea that you're the
killer and so you are put in that
position and you can feel that guilt and
feel complicit and
whatever that is a kind of ethical kind
of configuration of a subject where it's
just like oh then you can feel bad and
be like we're all complicit in the
exploitation of sex workers who you know
there's that there can be that moment
and this film won't let you do that
right so so you know so so there's that
you know so I mean I think this is also
like the interesting and sort of weird
thing about this film that I haven't a
hundred percent made up my mind on no
matter how like sort of like you know in
in the in the sort of structure of a
presentation I'm just like this is what
I think about this film but there's a
lot of things about the film and I still
don't know what I think about mmm and
that is sort of about like about like
the function of ethics in this film
right heat so I kind of tend to feel
like what it's primarily doing is just
making you question right like like like
what what kind of ethical subjects you
can be or you can you know it what kind
of ethical subjectivity you can have you
know but you know but please know that I
was going to go on to this other thing
so yeah no absolutely absolutely right
and so you know and and you know that's
part of why she's like whoa I'm using
this technology to kind of you know this
the other thing about this it's so
interesting and god I should I should
talk about this is that um so you know
one of the things that I don't well okay
so one of the things that that is like I
said kind of unusual about
Gumi is that you know she wasn't the
sort of good daughter right even though
in a lot of ways the narrative tried to
make her be that after it you know it
got but but it just became this huge
hyper visible thing that like just you
know and it was like a major big deal
right um so you know I said that um the
title of the film is you know bloodless
in English but the title of the film in
Korean is tongue to Chun which is the
actual name of the camp town right and
and you know that's because like Tong du
Chun means something in South Korea like
people know what that means in part
because of younger me right um so I mean
and also it's just this huge camp town
and you know it's just like kind of a
fact of life but you know mmm so um so
there is that and so that's really
interesting to see and what Joe and
other folks have said is just like well
you know the the fact that South Korea
there was a huge sort of mobilization
around young you know doesn't
necessarily mean that South Korea has
somehow you know like escape to like
sort of you know us neo-colonial sort of
pressure whatever it's just a
convergence of different kinds of things
right the the thing that I was going to
talk about though was you know one of
the things that I'm not a hundred
percent sure about how I feel is that
that hurt this like sort of dead and
violated body is represented at all
right I mean and it's in the mirror and
you could maybe not say whatever but
it's there right and that's a huge
conversation that has been had in a lot
of different context and I tend to be
myself of the of the perspective of sort
of like not representing that like so
for example one of the things that I
deliberately don't do in this
presentation and you know is describe
how she was tortured and raped and
violated right because it was pretty
grass like a
if you read about her not show but other
people who have written about her are
pretty graphic write about and and from
the beginning I was just like yeah no
I'm not gonna do that right so the and
so there's sort of this way in which you
know Gina may having made this decision
to represent this this kind of battered
body right is one of those moments right
just like Oh Gina what were you doing
right but on the other hand this is the
part that's so interesting and you know
help me with this so what had happened
was because this was sort of this whole
thing there were these photographs right
of the motel room and her body and
whatnot that circulated everywhere right
in newspapers and what have you and Gina
was a part of a group of Korean and
Korean diceberg feminists who like
basically worked to get that scrubbed so
if you type in you know me into Google
that image no longer circulates right
and so it's not like she she she doesn't
have a simple relationship to this idea
of like no like all images must be free
like let them circulate like quite the
opposite like she's not a kind of like
we can censor images like film can't be
sent a not at all she's just like censor
this crap you know so so you know so
that the sort of representation of her
in the film right I don't know it's it's
complicated right and that's all I
actually have that's as far as I've
gotten in terms of theorization like
these complicated
it's where the bodies were just you know
the method mm-hmm the currents was so
graphic that they the military decided
to take war to behavior and through that
construct the idea of the gentle mmm-hmm
disrupt at all yeah and what's so
interesting is that the military then
goes to be our it's a kind of recover
yeah to recuperate that idea uses the
character to disrupt even that mm-hmm
it doesn't matter if it's air or ground
mmm-hmm it is all unethical yeah no
basically and and you know and also I
mean you know Katherine moons Katherine
moons book is called sex among allies
right and it's like so that's also this
thing that this does which is like you
know a US Army medic right a medic right
who is in like his job is ostensibly to
like save people's lives right kills us
kills this woman really brutally right
and in that and in that sort of like you
know
training simulation right like she's the
ally right she's not right and so this
this context is very much about yeah
like how the violence of militarism like
does not discriminate actually right
like exactly in that way right like the
IITs like you know we can train you to
be really good at this
and it's just like no you don't even
have to be you know what I mean like
yeah yeah so thank you I will look at
that book Kimberly and then Lee
yes no no yeah no you know she um she
said that she tried like multiple times
like she would try and she would she's
you know I can't remember a hundred
percent sure she was just like it's just
like maybe I'll do a documentary you
know maybe I'll write a feature film
right maybe I'll you know and she said
she kept trying and just just completely
kept not being able to do it and then
she was just like and then I thought VR
and then I was just able to do it yeah
like she found out about VR figured out
how to do VR like super cheap right she
strapped like ten GoPro cameras onto a
pole right and then filmed everything
and then filming took two weeks but
post-production stitching it all
together took like months yeah
so yeah yeah so so it she tried for four
decades right like because you know this
was this happened when she was in
college right and then she kind of
became filmmaker and made Holly seen
lots of films and throughout she just
kept wanting to make a project about
this um and she just kind of found that
they all stalled out and then she's just
like well what about VR and then it just
happened that's how she represents it
yeah yeah
yeah yeah no it's really true so you
know I haven't talked to her about sort
of the aesthetic choices of this but you
know it's not unlike a lot of her other
her she's just a very beautiful
filmmaker right like her films are just
very very beautiful and this is a really
beautiful film right and so yeah that is
that is the question right and it's also
a very kind of indie film kind of
beautiful right like the frame of the
the the the way that you know scenes are
composed and and you know shots are
framed and things like that you know so
so that is really interesting right
because because these scenes are very
very beautiful and so that's also
question like are you aestheticizing
this context you know are you you know
and yeah it's totally you know arguable
that you are I mean this this makes this
camp town look beautiful and you know
I've never actually been in a camp town
because that's not like the kind of
place you just kind of wander into but I
highly doubt that it's like good looking
but um you know so um and and that's
just like because you know Gina is this
very like you know all these different
way she's like very elite you know she's
you know trained in a certain way like
she you know has a certain kind of
aesthetic right
and this kind of like there's like there
is this kind of greenish this to this
particular scene but a lot of the scenes
are in this and in other things are kind
of this I see blue clean Isetta sized
feeling you know so there is definitely
that what's really interesting is that
that last scene in the motel room it's
like the overall aesthetic feel of it is
just kind of dingy anis it's like very
yellow
you know everything's really yellow and
you know so I mean a lot of this is very
kind of exigencies of filming the way
that she did so I don't want to say that
that was necessarily deliberate right I
mean the room that she uses a can actual
motel room that is being used currently
for sex work and and she speaking of
verisimilitude though what is so weird
as it in some ways she's so invested in
that idea she talks about how she and
her production staff got the exact kind
of linoleum they used to use like in
1990 like an older version and like
scarred it up and made it look old and
really know Liam that it's so weird I
don't know what to do with that either
so and so that that so you know that
room she you know made both was kind of
battered looking and dingy and she also
made you know battered looking and dingy
and then the lighting I imagine was not
a hundred percent in her control you
know so so that is you know much less
aestheticized then or in a different way
than this right um so so yeah there are
lots of things about that you know that
there are lots of things about this film
and that's I think a part of why I'm
interested in looking at it that you
know can sort of cannot be sort of read
as like yes sticking it to the man or
whatever you know
for lack of a better term I have to come
up with a better term than that you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely
yeah absolutely absolutely I'm so glad
you raised that because that's the thing
about the horror part of it that's
really interesting so you know you know
what's interesting is that you know when
I first saw it which was like very very
early you know there was a very early
screening of this at UCLA because that's
where she teaches and you know we went
to see it and and afterwards we were
like oh my god that was a horror film
right and and you know and I was you
know like googling this film just to
sort of and like there's some you know
one of the first things that comes up
it's like Gina Kim's horror film
bloodless you know so people really
recognize it that way
you know I so I actually want to
reference the work of a grad student of
mine at UCLA who's actually working on
the horror genre as a kind of like the
kind of like effect of sort of white
like you know white nationalism in the
you know post-world War two ERA and one
thing that I think is really interesting
about the horror genre and yes I mean
the horror genre it does a lot of
containment right but what I think is
really interesting about the horror
genre which i think is also a part of
what's happening in general here because
there's a whole other part of this that
I've written out
that's about the undermining of empathy
right because you know this can be
thought of it like an issue film right
and when she says oh this will raise
awareness right that's placing it in the
trajectory of like the issue film right
like and so there's this kind of
tradition of documentary filmmaking that
comes out of like 60s and 70s that are
about like oh you know like third-world
newsreel or
you know about sort of taking up
documentary filmmaking as a way of like
you know like as a as like a part of
like these kind of social movement you
know interventions into kind of cinema
right and that has kind of also morphed
into like social documentary in the
issue film and that you like this
particular like Film Festival crowd like
that's kind of the audience for that
like you feel good about going and
watching this and you're just like oh
wow the plight of the blah blah blah
right the are right has been called the
ultimate empathy machine it's this very
yeah it's that's like kind of a cliche
in the media studies about like VR being
called the ultimate empathy machine so a
lot of VR sort of the way that the that
VR is used right there's a huge on
review are that's like so for example
the New York Times did this VR film
about like being a migrant like on a
boat in the Mediterranean right and a
refugee and you're like you're the
refugee mmm yeah yeah so then I took a
whole genre film right so an especially
VR film so there's this military
application
there's the gaming application in some
ways like I don't know maybe it's just
me but I feel like the gaming
applications are some of the like least
interesting even though it's like with
some of the biggest and then there's
like this whole kind of like a poor
educational apparatus you know a sort of
you know genre of VR film and that's
entirely operating on empathy right the
idea of VR is the ultimate empty machine
like you're gonna go oh my gosh there
was a VR film about being um so much
about migrants and refugees like
crossing the us-mexico border like in
the desert right so there's this part of
that and what I think is really in so my
students Stephanie Chang who's working
on horror
one of our arguments is that horror is a
genre that does not operate on the
register of empathy right so you know
like it's it's actually kind of like
against the kind of sentimental
melodrama or the you know it's a genre
that is like completely a sort of like
critical right and you know refuses
empathy right so in some ways I'm I
wonder if like the use of kind of horror
as a trope can be seen as a way of
displacing the ultimate empathy machine
I mean like so much of this is like the
fact that you're disembodied the fact
that you you know like don't you know
whatever like has these kind of empathy
displacing you know the fact that she
walks through you or whatever has all of
these sort of empathy displacing
tendencies I feel like you know but but
yeah I mean the thing about the sort of
making people anticipate the whatever I
mean there is definitely that and then
there's also that you can totally just
miss it you know so and it's really hard
to write about because it's like it even
on the sentence level really like it
does this but it might not so anyway
yeah absolutely
yes absolutely right and the linoleum
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um you know I don't
know like what she thought who that she
thought the viewer was going to be or
like you know what have you you know and
you know and and you know what she says
is like I said she's like you know
whenever I asked her like oh hey like
I'm going to you know get this talk at
Yale and like if it turns out that they
have a VR lab like you know can can you
know whatever she's always like yes yes
of course you know like like you know
and it's just like well you know thank
you so much for working on this like
every you know whatever like it'll
spread awareness
she'll feelings like that right so I
mean there's sort of this way in which
she just wants everyone to see it she
just wants everyone to see it you know
you know and and she of course because
she's this professional filmmaker with
many many credits and who just knows she
knows that it's only gonna be screened
at film festivals and universities and
museums and other places where they're
these you know yeah so you know so that
is kind of the inherent limitations of
VR like as a medium right now because
it's like you know yeah there are all
sorts of people with VR headsets but
like the gamers aren't you to see this
they're obviously not the audio you know
so um so yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
even this this this version of VR does
that sort of yeah yeah I mean I would
say yeah for sure yeah so I mean but you
know I think you know what what it would
sort of say like what I think bloodless
and Cho are kind of saying true for sure
bloodless you know in some ways yes and
somebody self but like what they're both
kind of saying is that that you know the
point to reckoning with trauma is not
resolution right the point to reckoning
with or the point to dealing with PTSD
in whatever therapeutic or military
applications is to resolve it or to cure
it or to fix it right and what I think
you know what Cho would say is like you
know you know that trauma itself or the
manifestations of this trauma including
likes a bloodless like I would think of
this bloodless the film itself is a kind
of manifestation of a kind of historical
trauma right
that in and of itself is isn't a
resolution right like it's not a cure
you know but that it's important for
these things to I mean not just
important but they just will exist you
know and the more you try to cure it or
the more you try to say we've redressed
this injustice we've put this guy in in
jail right or or like we've imprisoned
this person or we've you know like you
know we we can fix it we can we have the
technology I can rebuild him or whatever
you know you know like more the more the
ghosts are are going to come like the
ghosts have agency right because of that
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you